un encuentro muy constructivo el
almuerzo de trabajo de este lunes entre
Emmanuel macon y olas scholls tanto
Berlín como París destacaron la
cordialidad del intercambio y la solidez
de las relaciones bilaterales ambos
líderes evocaron un espíritu de trabajo
muy estrecho a mediano y largo plazos
uno de los acuerdos fue de hecho
establecer grupos de trabajo en las
áreas de energía defensa e Innovación En
ese sentido choles tuiteó que Francia y
Alemania permanecen muy cerca y están
abordando los desafíos juntos la
reuniones se extendió por tres horas más
de lo previsto pero fue un tiempo bien
aprovechado para dejar claras las
posiciones e intereses de ambos países
en los temas que corroen aún la relación
bilateral no obstante sin conferencia de
prensa ni declaración conjunta Aún es
difícil conocer en detalle Cuánto se
avanzó para resolver las discordias en
los referente a los precios del gas que
macron quiere limitar y George dejar en
manos del Mercado o sobre las
inversiones de Berlín en el área militar
que no incluyen participación alguna de
Francia al menos en el escudo
antimisiles antiaéreos que pretende
construir Alemania con tecnología
estadounidense e israelí en resumen
menos tensión en las relaciones pero
problemas de fondo aún por resolver